ein foto der kanzlerin
und noch ein paar hinterher viele
tausend bildern orange rang in den
letzten 20 jahren von angela merkel
gemacht woran ist die bekannteste
fotografen im politischen berlin wird
von akteuren vieler parteien auch für
offizielle fotos gebucht
politiker brauchen kinder für ihre
angebots weg für den zweck tanne
botschafter sondern politiker
überbringen muss also fotograf ich für
mich ist emotion und äste dich und wenn
diese beiden faktoren erreichen sind das
ist ein gutes bild
merkel mag wie chabrol sie sieht viele
ihrer bekanntesten bilder hat die
französin gemacht darunter auch viele
offizielle protest ich mag diese foto
hier sehr ich sehe auch in dieses bild
doch viel was ich persönlich gut findet
und ich mag diese zu hören aspekt in
dieses bild
1989 kommt angela merkel als
quereinsteigerin in die politik die
naturwissenschaftlerin gilt schnell als
abwägend und nachdenklich ich glaube
dieser wunsch nach kontrollierter
kommunikation speist sich aus ihrem
politikstil der sozusagen dinge vom ende
her denkt wenn ich sage mir überlege wo
will ich denn hin muss ich mir auch
überlegen wie will ich mit meiner
kommunikation das denn erreichen das
spricht sozusagen gegen zu voreiliges zu
schnelles kommunizieren am anfang ihrer
karriere ist angela merkel auch egal wie
sie aussieht frisur und kleidung passend
für die kameras so etwas interessiert
sie nicht das hat sie lernen müssen sie
hat gelernt dass sozusagen
kontrolliert das auftreten auch
reduziertes auftreten sie stärker macht
sie
auch unnahbarer aber auch seriöser macht
das hilft ihr 2006 als die
internationale finanzkrise ganze staaten
bedroht auf griechenland merkels
strenger europäischer sparkurs macht sie
dort zum feindbild der presse in
deutschland ist die zustimmung um so
größer
[Musik]
klare haltung auch 2015 flüchtlingskrise
die wohl größte herausforderung merkels
die kanzlerin öffnet die grenzen ihre
wichtigste botschaft wird schnell zum
geflügelten wort wir haben so vieles
geschafft wir schaffen das wir schaffen
das und wo uns etwas im wege steht muss
es überwunden werden
doch es läuft nicht alles nach plan in
europa verweigern sich vor allem
osteuropäische staaten einen gemeinsamen
kurs in der flüchtlingsfrage und in
deutschland schüren rechte parteien die
angst vor anderen kulturen und bekommen
mehr zulauf
[Musik]
ich glaube dass sie vor allem menschen
überfordert hat mit ihrem sehr
reduzierten kommunikationsstil in der
flüchtlingskrise wo viele menschen nach
einer anfänglichen euphorie am ende dann
doch sehr verunsichert waren und sich
nicht richtig mitgenommen fühlten von
der kanzlerin
dazu kommt auch die konkurrenz durch die
sozialen medien die fotografin lotte
raum beobachtet dass die politische
kommunikation immer schneller aber auch
schwieriger wird
das kann ich verstehen dass sauber der
politik die brauchen vielleicht ein
bisschen längere erklärung als ort diese
kurze botschaft aber heute das ist der
achte die kommunikation
und manchmal entstehen botschaften auch
ungeplant als merkel 2017 ein gespräch
mit dem russischen präsidenten genervt
mit den augen rollt wird das schnell zum
internet hit denn ihr gesicht spricht
auch nach 16 jahren kanzlerschaft gern
bände
auch ein internet hit merkel in
altertümlicher universitäts kleidung bei
ihrem letzten besuch in den usa es sind
wohl auch solche momente wie ihr
persönliche geständnisse zum ende ihrer
kanzlerschaft entlocken wahrscheinlich
werden wir
gewohnheitsmäßig verschiedene gedanken
in den kopf kommen was ich jetzt
eigentlich machen müsste und dann wird
mir ganz schnell einfallen das was jetzt
ein anderer macht und ich glaube das tut
mir sehr gut gefallen ich glaube dass
die menschen in diesem land diesen
reduzierten politikstil und diese
reduzierte politik kommunikation von
angela merkel noch vermissen werden
alles um uns herum wird aufgeregter
social media die medien alles wird
reduziert da wird wird wirt knackiger
und angela merkel ist sozusagen auch
kommunikativ der ruhepol es nützt doch
nichts wenn die politik genauso
aufgeregt ist wie die medien das
shopping wird auch merkels nachfolger
noch oft fotografieren der oder die wird
sicher viel darüber nachdenken was man
anders machen könnte als die vorgängerin
und auch was nicht
[Musik]